an operation to disinfect the city of
Herat is in full swing a task force has
been sent out to clean the streets
hospitals and government buildings to
counter the spread of corona virus the
western afghan city is the epicenter of
the outbreak the first cases were linked
to people returning from neighboring
Iran health officials are scrambling to
prevent a rapid spread of the virus our
biggest worry now is not the virus
coming from Iran but rather an increase
in community infections in Herat
province the virus is spreading fast
among families we're not able at this
stage to track all those infected people
but so far 30% of those tested came up
positive in a country where family
connections are strong the authorities
are struggling to convince people SEF
isolate man is among the millions of low
wage workers badly affected by the
restrictions imposed by the authorities
to contain the pandemic after years of
war Afghanistan faces many challenges
instability poverty and the declining
economy from the last 27 days I was not
able to go out to the marketplace to
sell water melons because of the
lockdown now we are running out of
crucial food items at home such as flour
rice and beans
Rama's wife tested positive for kovat 19
a few weeks ago Fatima was treated in a
local hospital and she has since
recovered we met her the moment she was
released from the hospital but started
to walk after my admission to this
hospital doctors gave me medicine and
also injections after a few days they
took blood samples and the tests came
out negative they asked me how I felt I
told them I was feeling very good now
I'm going home
[Music]
as the virus spreads fast thousands of
Afghan refugees have returned from Iran
and Pakistan in recent weeks in Herat
officials say they are taking all
necessary measures to contain the
pandemic more fail and are wholly
DePrima what the Visayas team
we have stopped enough food items so we
can help 400,000 people our goal is to
ensure enough food reserves for as long
as the lockdown continues we are also
working on improving health facilities
but for a country seeking to heal the
scars of war the pandemic poses more
challenges to a government that's
already struggling with shortage of
ventilators masks and hand sanitizers
hash Mahabharat al Jazeera